uh i think i can repair dylan and marco
but the others are
the idea that they are all the same
thing and they could all come together
and sort of help each other that to me
felt like it was part of dna of the
story that we were already trying to
tell
and that gave me an entry point to
actually get them together so that it
was a story element and an emotional
thing
okay
i gotta go yeah i got it you okay they
grow and they change and they evolve
from different writers different artists
in the case of the films different
actors that's why the marvel characters
have persevered so long through decades
and then you have the fun of starting to
pitch it to the actors and doing
something that is worthy of their time
and of their energy and stepping back
into this role
i had butterflies in those meetings with
toby and andy hoping that they would
sign up this is peter parker peter
parker spider-man spider-man there are
other me's from another dimension this
is the wizard that i was telling you
about